LARRY ARNN: You're saying that
these people are not angels.
If they get a discretion,
sooner or later some of them
are going to abuse it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In our Constitution reader,
we read the Progressives.
John Dewey's argument is, it's
a new world, really different.
And as the world changes,
he goes on to argue,
it changes how we think.
John Dewey says,
those principles
in the Declaration
of Independence,
he says those fit for a
pioneer-agrarian society.
People thought like
that, right, back then.
And so everything's changed now.
The old idea was, we're human.
We're capable of really great
things, says the Federalist.
And we're capable of really bad
And so we need to arrange the
government so that there's
a bias in favor of the
good things we can do.
And government should be
limited, just strong enough
to protect us from one another.
And don't give it absolute
power, because men are not
angels, true enough, and
they have to have government,
but angels do not govern men.
That's one world.
And another world is, wow,
look how much more we can
do by using these techniques.
Let's do it.
Let's get going here.
Right?
Let's solve these problems.
Let's get these checks and
balances out of the way.
Let's stop this
kind of government
that's offset against
itself so it's always
hampered and always a problem.
Right?
That's the argument.
And if you just look at the
power of modern science,
look at the incredible
things it can achieve,
doesn't that argument
have great force?
But you tell me.
What's wrong with the argument?
SPEAKER 1: I don't
know that I'll
be able to fully
developed this, but it
seems like the last
couple of days,
we've really established
that the true genius
of the Constitution was
separating the sovereignty
from the power and keeping
those two things separate so
that they can check one another
and keep an eye on one another.
It seems as you move towards
this bureaucratic structure
that we're talking about,
you create other tyrants.
You create health problems or
economic problems as tyrants.
So in order to combat
that, you have to--
they're arguing to recombine
that sovereignty and the power
and put them in the same
hands to combat that.
But then we forget that
fundamental principle
in the Declaration
of Independence,
"all men are created equal."
And when we yoke the
sovereignty and power again,
then we challenge
that very thing
that all men are created equal.
LARRY ARNN: You mean--
you're nodding.
What are you going to say?
SPEAKER 2: Well, we're talking
about how whether or not
the principles of
the Constitution
still apply in a
radically different world.
But even if it were
not an agrarian society
anymore, we're still
a society of humans,
and human nature doesn't change.
We still suffer
from the same ills
and make the same mistakes.
LARRY ARNN: So you're both
saying in different ways,
your argument is like
Madison's argument.
You're saying that these
people are not angels.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
LARRY ARNN: Right?
And so if they get a discretion,
sooner or later some of them
are going to abuse it.
You're saying that
doesn't change.
And you're saying that's nature.
The excellence of the
human being is nature.
And the fallings of the
human being are nature.
And nature doesn't
change, because remember,
we defined this term, nature.
Right?
And this term, nature,
governs, it starts with babies,
it starts with seeds.
But then it includes
this fallenness
of human beings, right,
this capable of greatness,
capable of evil, both, and
that arrangement of government.
And if you set out
to overcome that,
then here's the final question.
If you can design your
society any way you want to,
what standard will
you use to design it?
What can give you any guidance?
I can tell you what
happened in Nazi Germany,
right, because they just
go right down this road.
And what it means
is the guide that
remains after everything
else has been eliminated
is strength.
Only power can arbitrate.
Now, what that
means, then, I argue,
is that these problems that
come up in society, sure enough,
one of the reasons we
have the government
is to help solve these problems.
But if we think about
it, we understand
that, yeah, of course, we
need to make things better
in society.
We need to treat people as
well as we can treat them.
But also we have to
be a little suspicious
of concentrating power.
SPEAKER 3: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore
all of Hillsdale College's
online courses.
They are free and for
everyone who loves to learn.